welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and a new trailer for she-hulk has
just dropped this is going to be my live
reaction to it we have yet to see
tatiana maslany's full green vase and
her appearance as the hulkify jennifer
walters with she-hulk and hulk not being
inexpensive characters for marvel
studios to animate and bring to life
especially on disney plus so it's
incredible that we're seeing this as a
disney plus title looks like it is
coming august 17th you know we're gonna
be covering it like crazy so here's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna react to it give
you my initial thoughts and impressions
and then tomorrow will be my in-depth
frame by frame breakdown of this trailer
so let's see what we're working with
here we go
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you is that the car wreck
why she needs a transfusion
[Applause]
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a super human law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
abominations background a frustrating
family because we didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
i'm gonna oh my god
yes yes yes
no
no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
i
uh i
i can't
i can't honestly tell you
exactly what i am feeling right now but
holy [ __ ] this is marvel's horniest show
yet
look i don't want to be gross about this
but i'm just saying there's a lot of
guys out there who are watching this
trailer and taking it to go okay so
let's start with who jennifer walters is
she is the cousin to bruce banner in the
comics jennifer walters is an attorney
who ends up running afoul of some
organized crime entities and they gun
her down she gets shot so she
desperately needs a blood transfusion
which is where bruce banner comes in
gives her a blood transfusion and then
that blood ends up giving her similar
powers to bruce banner where she's able
to hulk out but the key difference
between her and hulk is that in the
comics most of the time she has more
control over her hulking abilities this
show looks like it's doing a similar
origin story but there is a car accident
and i assume that is what requires her
to need some kind of blood transfusion
now we have to wonder how exactly they
were able to get that blood out of bruce
banner i mean he is in permanent
smarthold form after avengers end game
so would any needle be able to pierce
his skin probably not but we have to
assume that after 18 months of testing
in the gamma lab he probably has a lot
of his blood and his blood serum on
supply i think what i'm loving most
about this trailer is the tone of the
she-hulk character what's so great about
the she-hulk comics is that it has like
a satirical sense of humor in a lot of
ways she reminds you of a deadpool she
breaks the fourth wall she comments on
how ridiculous her name is and her how
ridiculous her existence is and she owns
it she's one of the smartest one of the
funniest and just one of the fiercest
and coolest characters in the comics and
even when she stays hulked out she
continues to be an awesome attorney she
defends all kinds of people she actually
ends up working a case in front of the
tva at one point and i also just like
how the show isn't afraid of the
inherent sexuality of the character
that's another thing that the comics
totally embraced the she-hulk character
in the comics in a lot of ways was
really a
self-satire of marvel comics and the way
those comics would completely objectify
female characters with completely
unrealistic body proportions she-hulk
embraces all that satire and she makes a
lot of sexual references and sexual
innuendos and puns wearing all of that
on her face as this trailer does and
again i swear i'm not trying to be gross
about this but that has been something
really missing from the marvel cinematic
universe the fact that the fundamental
aspect of humanity is the fact that we
all have sexual urges and throughout all
the marvel titles there hasn't been a
lot of references to that they usually
keep it way too safe so the fact that
this show's willing to flirt i think
it's gonna be great now our friends at
epic hero shop just dropped their epic
summer collection these t-shirts and
tanks are inspired by various alcohol
brands with the twist of nerd they've
got asgard ipa merch from fat thor
brewing company bat cardi sokovia vodka
and of course there's no laws when
you're drinking wakanda claws
now keep your actual summer beverages
cold with these soup can koozies
inspired by various marvel costumes
they've got captain american spider can
in the iron can mk32 you can't put a
suit of armor around the world but you
can put one around your drink they've
also dropped their full multiverse of
madness collection with some spoilery
items that showcase the big cameos and
moments from the film epic hero is
always putting out cool creative merch
inspired by our favorite content you
better believe they had shirts for
agatha all along
or loki variant almost immediately after
those concepts entered our vocabulary
and hey if you have a background in
graphic design epic hero is actually
looking for designers to join them at
their austin office so click the link in
the description and prepare to have an
epic summer at epicheroshop.com with
their summer themed designs and their
full multiverse of madness collection
but we gotta talk about tim roth coming
back as abomination emil blonsky i'm so
excited that we're getting this phase
one callback now of course we saw
abomination in chongqi and tim roth was
credited for the role i guess for the
vocalization of it but we didn't
actually see tim roth in that movie i'd
love that they're bringing him back on
the show and that he's capable of
de-powering back into human form it
actually seems like this field that
they're keeping him in might prevent him
from hulking out maybe emitting some
kind of a frequency actually i think the
last we heard of blonsky was in an agent
to shield episode where coulson
threatened another agent by saying oh
i'm going to send you up to alaska to
guard blonsky's cold storage vault or
something like that i like how we're
exploring the whole criminal justice and
containment aspect of the mcu she's now
working as an attorney in this high
security facility it looks like it's in
a remote desert location far away from
any civilization just like how sword was
introduced in one division it looks like
she-hulk is expanding this corner of the
world now jamila jamil is playing
titania mary mcferrin who's considered
really the arch nemesis of she-hulk in
the comics who possesses similar
superhuman strength and durability after
being exposed to some alien technology
so it's not exactly the same process
that creates titania that creates
she-hulk but they are like considered
evenly matched strength-wise it looks
like here she may be like a rival
attorney uh it looks like bruce now has
a residence on this uh remote island
which is interesting that he'd want to
live here it's not like he has to worry
about uh raging out and causing any
damage but i guess the guy deserves a
bit of retirement there's a very quick
sighting in this trailer of a character
i'm pretty sure is frogman eugene
patilio a relatively minor character in
the marvel comics who often intersects
with the avengers in various ways
a total goofball of a character who's
got who basically isn't powered he just
has a suit with these powered leaping
coils that allow him to like
leap up over buildings looks like he is
in the process of jumping here we know
from the description that benedict wong
as wang is going to show up in this
which is funny how really the mcu is
becoming the wong cinematic universe i
would say but i assume that wong's gonna
appear in this to explain what his
relationship with abomination was in
chiang chi really i'm just most excited
for the show as a legal comedy one that
can deal with the legal issues of the
entire mcu that's a way that we could
get matt murdock charlie cox to show up
in the show everything that could be
going on with the dark avengers slash
the thunderbolts which is really what i
think uh galena belova
and
john walker and perhaps abomination
might be tied in with this is exactly
the kind of show where you can imagine
julie louis dreyfus showing up as val
and i pointed this out before but we're
starting to get a sense of the general
law and order of the mcu
the uh multiverse of madness just showed
us the living tribunal which is uh the
cosmic legal authority for everything in
the mcu beneath them we have tiers like
the tva and the india ad so it really
makes sense to see legal drama unfold
from the ground level yeah i'm seeing a
lot of griping about uh the uncanny
valley-ness the awkwardness of uh the
animation on the face to be honest
maybe i just have like an internal
filter
where that stuff doesn't really bother
me that much because really whenever i
watch a marvel thing all of it just kind
of looks like a living breathing walking
cartoons anyway and i just kind of go
with it i mean that's just me i
understand if it takes you out of it
also they have a few more months and
they always continue to improve the vfx
between trailer and release overall
what's more important to me is the sense
of humor the tone the writing the
storytelling the world building and this
show seems to have all that in spades so
i'm super excited for she-hulk a healthy
wholesome level of excited trust me let
me know your favorite part of this
trailer again there's a lot in here i
really need to go through it frame by
frame i'm sure i missed quite a bit of
stuff
so the breakdown is coming out tomorrow
you're gonna love it
again you can support me rockstars by
checking out our merch options at new
yorkstartmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more breakdowns everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you